في وقت ترك سكان العالم الكمامات وعدو
لممارسه حياتهم بصفه عاديه بدل وضع مختلفا
تماما في الصين التي يبدو انها ستعود
للمربع الاول بتسجيلها معدلات قياسيه في
اصابتي كورونا بعد اسابيع فقط من تخلي
بكين عن سياساتها صارمه لاحتواء الوباء
ملاحظات مسربه من مسؤوليه الصحه الصينيين
تكشفوا عن بلوغ عتبه المليون اصابه يوميا
في مقاطعه
وحدها كما ان مستشفيات بكين تعجه بالمرضى
وما يقرب من 250 مليون شخص في الصين
اصيبوا بفيروس كورونا خلال ال 20 يوما
الاولى من شهر ديسمبر اي ما يعادل 18% من
السكان وفقا لتقديري تقديرا داخليا من
كبار مسؤولي الصحه في البلاد وهو ما دفع
سلطات البلاد لوقفي نشر هذا الاصابات
اليوميه بفايروس كورونا من قبل لجنه الصحه
الوطنيه اثر تفجر الاصابات في سابقه هي
الاولى من نوعها اما في المدن الساحليه
وتحديدا مدينه سنغاف الواقعه شرقي البلاد
فهي تشهد بين
490,530,000 اصابه جديده بكرونا يوميا
بارتفاعا يقدر بنحو 10%
وتوقعت حكومه مقاطعه دينكشي شرق البلاد ان
يصاب ثمانون في المئه من سكانها اي نحو 36
مليون شخص بالفايروس حتى مارس المقبل
واضافت ان اكثر من ثمانيه عشره الف مصاب
بكافد تم ادخالهم الى المستشفيات الكبرى